symboliquement évidemment c'est très
fort vive c'est par là que transitent
les armes qui qui viennent d'europe pour
être acheminées ensuite à l'est de l'est
du pays au moment où emmanuel macron
parle de l'europe et de sa réaction il
l'a fait un peu le bilan en expliquant
que les choses qui avaient été mises en
place n'avait été rapidement que il y
avait eu des sanctions qui avait été mis
en place très rapidement et que du côté
de la france et de l'europe on avait agi
de façon très claire contre l'agresseur
russe et c'est vrai que cette cette
visite est éminemment symbolique du côté
de cette de cette frontière d'autant
plus qu' il doit ensuite aller en
moldavie moldavie qui est sous la
pression russe avec cette région de
transnistrie si la france a renforcé son
dispositif et va encore le renforcer
c'est parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'inquiétudes dans cette région certains
soupçonnent les russes de d'avancer vers
odessa et en même temps de semer le
trouble du côté de la transnistrie voilà
et c'est le frapru si elle est confirmée
est effectivement un qui serait là aussi
un symbole à un moment alors de ce
déplacement du chef de l'état français